regardez qui nous rejoint là ce qui
m'intéressait c'était un officier voilà
sophie ak le personnage de même aller
c'est plus qu'une incarnation c'est
vraiment ce que je te disais à françois
c'est quand je gêne joaillier film j'ai
senti que j'avais la même voie que quand
j'ai des livres dans ma tête
comment vous êtes arrivé à sa fin comme
vous avez libre dans la thèse qui était
écrit pour un film qui a été écrit vos
françois je pense ce qui correspond aux
films qu'il aime enfin elle en a fait
beaucoup il est très différent mais je
crois qu'il était très touché par cette
femme caractère de cette femme et sa vie
autour de ce père qui est un personnage
très charismatique très insupportable
est magnifique très libre et voilà et on
parle de choses qui sont les choses de
la vie les choses des liens familiaux à
travers des événements qui nous arrive
et qui sont difficiles voilà si on